to Stephen Fox News if you just take the
day the daytime news reporters they're
very different from the evening more
like entertainers so I think if you know
what you're looking at but but my point
is you can't rely on any one source you
have to go to multiple sources including
online sources and just evaluate them
and there are sites that evaluate the
biased liberal or conservative bias of
different uh media sources you just have
to do that uh you know and NPR I don't
trust So Much Anymore AP Associated
Press I I feel is fairly objective about
how they present things no one's
completely unbiased of course but some
multiple sources I mean and that now
there's so many online
really you just have to kind of do a
little bit of your own fact checking
[Music]
me today is the publisher of skeptic
magazine a presidential fellow at
Chapman University the host of the
Michael Shermer show and author of the
new book I've got it right here in my
hand conspiracy why the rational believe
the irrational Michael Shermer welcome
back to the Reuben report all right nice
to see you Dave nice to be back good to
see you my friend now before I do
anything else here uh you have one of
the largest stacks of books I've ever
seen behind you is this some kind of
Ploy like if there's uh an earthquake or
something books crash on you clip goes
viral it's very clever and very clever
killed by a conspiracy
by a plethora of conspiracies yes it's
such by your own conspiracy book that
would be odd uh it is good to see you my
friend uh we we did about 30 seconds
before we started recording here but you
have been on this show probably a dozen
times in one car Incarnation or another
um and uh you also have written 400
billion books I I did the math on that
no what what is this speed this is like
16 18 what is it 15th book yeah first
one was first real book uh as as Mr
skeptic was why people believe we're at
things 1997. so I average you know like
two a year something like that this
other this conspiracy this is last real
book was 2018 Heaven's on Earth so it
takes me you know three to four years
really on average uh was this was this a
little different I mean a lot your books
obviously they're they're dense and
thoughtful and interesting and one of
the things that I always credit you for
is you you don't pretend you made up
every idea you credit people accordingly
and you call back to people and those
sorts of things but there's a lot of
research in this book you had to dive
into a lot of stuff does that make it
more fun or less fun to write a book
where you're where you're unpacking and
going across all sorts of mediums to
figure out who believes what and why
they believe it I do like to cite uh
authors that actually do the work unlike
some authors who whom I won't name not
you I mean just there's some academics
thank you thank you there's some
academics that are not especially
generous about recognizing where they
got that research there's actually a
huge body of literature on conspiracies
and conspiracy theories why people
believe them sociology of it social
psych cognitive psych you know
anthropology of beliefs and so on
there's a lot in there so I summarize
all that but then try to push the
Frontiers a little bit with some of my
own ideas I constructed a three-part
tripartite you might call it her
three-legged stool of of uh conspiracism
proxy conspiracism tribal conspiracism
and constructive conspiracism so there's
kind of an overarching theoretical model
that holds together all the different
parts so while most of the details of
course are other people people's
research I've kind of put it all
together in an integrative hole under
that rubric yeah and I really liked how
you did that so as you said there are
sort of three sections to the book a
prologue that leads into it but but then
each one sort of leads into the next one
so I want to get into some of that but
broadly speaking uh one of the questions
I get the most these days if I do a
public event or if I'm doing a q a
online or whatever is people say to me
where do you get your news how do you
know what to believe and I find it's
getting increasingly more difficult to
answer that I you know we're all going
into our little ideological Echo
Chambers I do my best to to not be in
there all the time but it's it's getting
tough for everybody and as I often say
if you're watching MSNBC you basically
live in a different world as the Fox
News person and I think everyone right
now in a modern sense is struggling with
this so the the book for that reason
feels very relevant because I think
everyone's going through some version of
a conspiracy theory to some extent
yeah well so here's one solution I I
actually get print newspapers every day
I get the New York Times or say the New
York oh where's my Wall Street Journal
here's my Wall Street okay I got my Wall
Street Journal oh here it is and the
Wall Street Journal there we go so I add
them up and divide by two to get the
truth
division The Wall Street Journal would
be far more factual than the New York
Times which I think has gone really off
the deep end as you know you know Barry
Weiss they were they were so out of
control that Barry White says a liberal
felt she couldn't even stay there
anymore so when you pick up the New York
Times Are you basically going all right
they screwed this one up Ah that's a
deflection this is a confusion
Etc well the Wall Street Journal you
know that separating the opinion section
from the news section uh you know
they're both biased in each direction
that we all know about and that's true
for any of the news sources you might
want to name you have to separate the
like just even Fox News if you just take
the date the daytime news reporters
they're very different from the evening
more like entertainers so I think if you
know what you're looking at but but my
point is you can't rely on any one
source you have to go to multiple
sources including online sources and
just evaluate them and there are sites
that evaluate the biased liberal or
conservative bias of different uh media
sources you should have to do that you
know and NPR I don't trust So Much
Anymore AP Associated Press I I feel is
fairly objective about how they present
things no one's completely unbiased of
course but some multiple sources I mean
and that now there's so many online
really you just have to kind of do a
little bit of your own fact checking and
if you do yeah well isn't that almost
one of the the biggest problems we have
in in this technological adolescence
that we're in that the average person
that even if they want to stay informed
on current events what's going on in the
world the economy whatever it might be
they don't have the time to to go okay
I'm going to read the Times And The Wall
Street Journal and I'll see what they're
saying on Fox and MSNBC and then they
just kind of put their hands up and they
and they check out I think I think we're
getting a lot of that actually
so the the subtitle of the book why the
rational believe the irrational my point
is that uh people that believe
conspiracy theories are not tin foil hat
uh idiots they're me and you everybody
surveys show everybody believes at least
one conspiracy theory and one reason for
that is my constructive conspiracism a
lot of them are true
so it pays to be a little constructively
paranoid uh just in case but so for most
for the most part most people are
rational about their daily lives you
know they they get the kids off to
school they hold jobs you know they keep
a gas in the tank and food in the fridge
and they have a social life and they're
just normal
about things that they could do
something about now if you take some of
the big conspiracy theories like the
rigged election say of 2020. I how would
I check that to know what's going on I
you have to rely on sources that have
the resources and access to check fact
check things like that I wouldn't even
know who to call in Ohio or Georgia or
Arizona to ask you know what about that
truck that pulled up at three in the
morning because that grainy video was
kind of suspicious you know so here we
rely on people that we should trust and
we have traditionally maybe not so much
anymore but for me it uh whatever
questions I had were put to rest when
attorney general Bill Barr said well you
know we had the entire resources the
Department of Justice and we looked into
it and we looked here and we'd text that
and so on and so forth didn't find
anything it's like okay well end of
story as far as I was concerned what do
you say what do you say to the people
that will go well Bill Barr is just part
of the machine that would produce that
sort of lie because that of course as
you know you're the expert in this I
mean conspiracies they jump from one
sort of dead seeming dead end to a new
place and then a new place and a new
place underneath so what do you say well
what I say is well then who who do you
trust what is your Source you know if
you don't trust the entire department of
justice if you don't trust the Trump
appointed attorney general or all the
Trump appointed judges in the cases that
he brought before the courts and so on
uh who would you trust and why would you
trust somebody else if not them I like I
like quoting Christopher Hitchens when
he says which he got from somebody else
which was that if you hear the pope say
he believes in God today you think well
Pope's doing his job again today that's
what he's supposed to do but if you're
the pope say you know I'm beginning to
have some doubts about God's existence
he's like huh he might be odd to
something right so when somebody on your
team or somebody you trust says
something uh that you can pretty much
count on if Bill Barr said hey I you
know I found some suspicion well of
course he's a trump appointing
Republican maybe we need another source
but if he says if he would be motivated
to find fraud and he didn't then I I to
me that UPS the probability that there
was no fraud in the election that's just
kind of how to think about that kind of
conspiracy theory if you're looking for
more honest and thoughtful conversations
about Academia instead of non-stop
yelling check out our Academia playlist
and if you want to watch full interviews
on a variety of topics check out our
full episode playlist they're all right
over here and to get notified of all
future videos be sure to subscribe and
click the notification Bell